what is up everybody it's Adam Mack here
for anime uproar and horikoshi what are
you doing to us bro for Deku this man
can't catch a break as toga becomes even
more unhinged and goes completely
berserk with Sad Man's parade she may
have just killed one of the most
important hero students in the story and
what's worse she may have just nuked the
entire mha shipping debate and we need
to talk about it right now you guys know
the drill if you enjoy my mha videos and
you want to see more in the future leave
a quick like and comment right now and
if you're new to the channel or you
watch my videos but you just haven't
taken the time to subscribe yet do me a
huge favor and make this the video do
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
seriously we're pushing for 2 million
subscribers here on the channel so every
subscription matters finally this video
will contain mha manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned in the previous chapter we
got to see the aftermath of the fiery
Showdown with Dobby and then we switched
Focus to the fight against toga and Sad
Man's parade toga is committed to
killing all the heroes in an act of
Revenge for twice's death and her mental
state has been deteriorating rapidly
throughout this final Arc as she becomes
more and more unhinged Sad Man's parade
continues to rage and it seems to be
overwhelming the heroes one by one with
most of the top heroes and hero students
out of commission after the Dobby and
all-for-one fights the responsibility to
stop toga falls on ochako and a few
other Heroes and hero students ocheko
knows that she can't stop Sad Man's
parade physically she can't win through
Force alone so she attempts to talk to
toga and to talk her down she tells toga
that her feelings of hatred and her
desire for Revenge are clouding the
purity of her love for her friends and
this is why she can't use the quirks of
the other villains ochako's words
definitely have an impact on toga but
not the kind of impact that ochako had
been hoping for instead of calming down
toga is infuriated by ochiko's words
to shut up because she doesn't know the
first thing about toga but as she says
these words togas twice mask begins to
fall apart exposing part of her real
face this physical deterioration of her
mask seems to reflect toga's
psychological deterioration but now at
least ochako knows which of the Clones
is the real toga the latest chapter
begins with yet another twist as toga
reveals that she is holding to you
hostage at knife point tsuyu was
captured because she had already been
injured back on okuto island and so she
wasn't able to dodge all those twice
clones in time ocheko calls out to tsuyu
and rushes to rescue her but she is met
by a furious toga toga yells at ochako
that her innocent heroism comes from the
fact that she was born into an easy life
whereas toga grew up as an outcast who
was rejected by everyone including her
own parents we see a flashback in which
little toga is crying after finding a
dead bird in her backyard her parents
find her there and instead of trying to
console her they accuse her of killing
the bird so that she could drink its
blood toga says it isn't true she found
the bird already dead in the yard and
this made her sad but her parents are
skeptical and they force her to undergo
Quirk counseling the counselor says that
this Quirk counseling will make toga
normal after all deviations like this
are common in children with strong
quirks but what does normal even mean
seriously what can be considered normal
in a world where quirks are common and
where so many people have become so
radically different from the norm and
not just like psychologically but on a
biological and genetic level the
counselor still vows to remove toga's
deviances like they never existed but if
these so-called deviances are so closely
connected to toga's very biology then
what would be left of toga if these
things are removed who would toga become
that is the fundamental question here we
see young toga walking through the park
and she looks at how others express love
and affection for each other she sees a
young couple holding hands she sees a
man playing with his dog she sees kids
playing and having fun but these loving
images are juxtaposed with everyone
telling toga that she looks like a
deviant and that she has to be normal
this contradiction that she doesn't
understand is beginning to drive her
crazy we see her biting her own fingers
so hard that it begins to bleed things
escalate quickly after that we see toga
crying and yet smiling at the same time
with blood stains on her hands her
parents are freaking out and asking if
she sucked the blood of one of her
classmates she says that the classmate
hurt themselves and she just wanted to
kiss it better and she doesn't see
what's wrong with that her parents tell
her that this is not normal drinking
blood is not normal under any
circumstances but toga doesn't
understand why that behavior is not
normal because it's normal to her it is
in line with the nature of her Quirk and
the natural desires that come from from
it so why is everyone telling her that
something that comes naturally to her
isn't normal it's obviously hard for us
quirkless individuals to fully
understand this predicament but if I
understand things correctly because of
the nature of her Quirk toga sees
drinking blood as something perfectly
natural like drinking water so when you
tell her that she's a deviant it's like
telling us that weird deviants for
getting thirsty and then drinking water
to quench our thirst it just doesn't
make sense to her however there is of
course an issue with this blood and
water comparison drinking water to
quench your thirst doesn't hurt anyone
but blood has to come from someone and
if you are drinking someone's blood you
are almost certainly hurting them in
some way even though toga finds this to
be completely normal society obviously
can't normalize drinking human blood as
an acceptable social practice and this
is the Crux of the problem as toga
recalls her parents saying that they
gave birth to a demon child something
that isn't even human the adult toga in
the present time sees a vision of
curious that woman from The Meta
Liberation Army whom she killed during
the my villain Academia Arc the illusion
of curious tells toga that all this time
she had been putting on a mask and
suppressing herself while sweeping her
true feelings under the rug all this
time toga has been attempting to become
someone else while keeping her own true
nature hidden away as toga is having
this inner dialogue slash mental
breakdown the fight between the clones
and hero students is still raging ochako
attempts to get closer to toga and tsuyu
Jiro then sees tuyu falling and she
rushes to grab her but Kami Woods who
already has the real to you warns Jiro
that that's not her Jiro then looks up
to see an evil clone of tsuyu rushing at
her and has more to you clones and even
Giro clones begin to appear the heroes
realize what's happening toga's twice
clones are drinking the blood that has
been spattered across the battlefield
and they are using that blood to
generate clones of the people whose
blood they found since tsuyu and jira
were both injured their blood was on the
battlefield and so they were both
successfully cloned by toga the heroes
and hero students are now being forced
to fight not only an army of twice
clones but also clones that look like
their own friends and comrades and just
like Jiro was initially tricked by the
tsuyu Clone many of the heroes will
likely be tricked in the same way and
that one mistake could lead to their end
in a matter of seconds things are
looking bad for the heroes and toga is
just as determined to exterminate all of
them as ever the real to you tries the
same approach that ochako tried earlier
she tries to talk to toga and she says
that at first she may have thought that
being a hero just means following the
rules all the time but that's no longer
the case in fact ochiko's priority right
now is not following the rules it's
trying to comfort toga because it's
clear that toga is suffering I mean okay
sure but ocheko is also trying to calm
toga down in order to save the LIE lives
of all the heroes and hero students on
the battlefield if we're being honest
ochako's first priority is still heroics
not being toga's friend I get that tsuyu
is trying to persuade toga here but from
the perspective of us readers we gotta
keep it real tuyu says that ochako
clearly isn't trying to arrest or kill
toga even though that would be easier
although it's a bit late ochako wants
toga to hear her out because maybe just
maybe when they talk things out they
could be able to finally truly
understand each other but toga isn't
listening as ochiko flies through the
air above the army of cones toga grabs
her and stabs her through the abdomen
with a knife even though toga here just
looks like another twice clone I assume
it's her because she was holding a knife
earlier when she was still holding tsuyu
captive toga says to tsuyu and ochako
that they are just too different because
she has never felt the blessings and
happiness that they speak of not even
once as ochako's own blood spills from
her body and begins to levitate in zero
gravity including blood that is
apparently coming from her mouth toga
thinks back to when twice asked her why
she didn't pick out a villain name yet
and that is how this insane chapter ends
and wow there is a lot to unpack here
about toga's character development but
first and foremost we have to talk about
this massive ochako twist ochako looks
like she was just severely injured by
toga this could be potentially a fatal
injury I mean yes this is Shonen and she
could totally survive it or some other
Shonen hijinks could happen but
horikoshi clearly wants us to worry
about ochako right now if we want to be
medical and scientific about it the fact
that ocho apparently has blood coming
from inside her mouth suggests that one
of her lungs may have been injured as
well which would make the injury even
worse but to be fair manga doesn't often
follow strict scientific rules when it
comes to injuries horikoshi is clearly
cooking something when it comes to the
whole toga situation and Ocho injury was
intended to show us that something
serious is happening here this is a
serious situation based on what that
illusion of curious was saying to toga
in this chapter and based on what twice
says to her about finally choosing a
villain name the implication is that as
crazy and unhinged as toga has been up
to this point she's actually been
holding herself back this entire time
she still hasn't gone full mask off
Village she's still been trying to
appear normal at least to an extent and
if this is true then I can't even
imagine what kind of absolute chaos we
can expect from a fully unfettered mask
off toga like what is about to happen
now is she gonna like kill everyone in
sight is she gonna start a cult is she
gonna become an e-girl the possibilities
are endless and terrifying and what is
going to be her villain name something
like yandere vampire chaos Gremlin place
your bets on toga's Villa name down in
the comments below also what is gonna
happen to Ocho Kona assuming the injury
is real and not the product of toga's
hallucinations or some sort of Clone
Shenanigans how serious is this injury
how will Decor react when he finds out
that one of his closest classmates and
biggest supporters has been hurt so
badly how will this turn of events
affect the war as a whole leave your
thoughts down in the comments below you
guys know the drill if you enjoy rmha
videos and you want to see more in the
future leave a quick like right now and
if you're new to the channel or maybe
you watch our videos regularly but you
just haven't taken the time to subscribe
yet do me a big favor and subscribe
right now we're trying to push for 2
million subscribers here on the channel
which would be absolutely epic as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see ya Space Cowboys